Nếu vực sông hồng, sông thay bình là hệ thống xong Linh Cuốc gia, trẻ qua bà nước Việt Nam, Trung Quốc và Lào,
với dịch tự nhiên 1,5 xói trị nghiệm kí lồ mấy phuông,
phân năm ở Việt Nam là tảm bí tảm nghiệm xấu trăm tảm bí kí lồ mấy phuông.
Đây là 1 cung cấp nước chú lực cho hơn 1 chữ hách ta đất nông nghiệm và như cầu dân sinh, công nghiệp.
Tòa nước vực hiện có 2,5 xói trăm 2 mì cầu trình thuy lợi.
Ông, 2,5 xói mốt của chữ, 1 xói mình tảm chăm 2 mì xấu đập dân, 2,5 xói trăm 5,5 xói trăm tảm mì mốt công,
2,5 xói mình kí lồ mấy kinh mương và 2,5 xói cấp nước sinh hỏa nông tôn.
Các công chính này phục vụ tối cho tảm chăm 5 mì bẩy gìm bà chăm hách ta đất cạnh tác 1,5 mốt ngìn hách ta đôi trồng thuy trăm,
cấp khoảng hư vị tảm mì bẩy tì mấy khội nước cho sinh hỏa.
Từ thoát nước cho 1 phẩy bà mì bẩy chữ hách ta đất nước nghiệp và bảo vệ hơn 18 triệu dân qua hệ thống đe dài 2,5 xói
linh tảm kí lồ mết. Tuy nhiên, tư năm 1 gìn chính trăm xì mươi đến nay, 1 nước cấp xong ngày càng xí dạm.
Dạy đạng 2 gí khu chăm 12,5 mốt nước hả liệu xong đà 2,5 mốt đình 2,5 xin tí mết 1 năm,
xong đô 3,5 xói xin tí mết 1 năm, xong thao 3 bẩy đến 1 xin tí mết 1 năm,
dương tại hành lội, xong hồng xam 1 đến 5 xin tí mết 1 năm.
Xong thay bình tại phải lại và phủ lương 3,5 xin tí mết 1 năm.
Mực nước hả thấp kéo theo xâm nhập mạnh an xô và đổi đồng 3,5 mốt đình 1,5 kí lồ mết,
ghi nhận độ mạnh lên tới xin về 3 tại cầu xe và xin tại ăn thổ trong vụ đông xun 2,5 xin 2,5 mốt đình 2,5 mốt.
Chứ thách thức này, cân đồng 1 có thể pháp công trình và phía công trình,
tư kiểm soát hay thác các soại đến cải tạo hệ thống thuy lợi.
Tăng cường công nghệ tư tích kiệp, trong dương đồng 1 và đều trình cơ cấu xảm sất nhằm sự dụng hiệu quả 1 nước.